this program is brought to you by Emory
University when States acquire nuclear
weapons they are fairly successful and
their international crises in terms of
deterring their opponents their
opponents tend to be much more
restrained in dealing with these nuclear
actors the implications from this hour
yes nuclear weapons can be a source of
stability but by no means would it
logically follow that we should actually
give nuclear weapons too many more
countries or even a select few countries
those states are at much greater risk to
be involved in international conflict
both as aggressors as well as defenders
and so proliferation itself is quite
dangerous yes it might be a less
likelihood of being involved in a major
regional war because it has weapons its
potential enemies such as is really the
United States are going to be more
restrained against them once they have
nuclear weapons basically there's going
to be very little to international
community could do to push Iran towards
addressing human rights issues or
freedom of the press or freedom of its
people the preceding program is
copyrighted by Emory University